aquí nos dan la función f x igual a 7 x
cuadrada menos 2 x todo esto dividido
entre 15 x + 5 y nos preguntan a qué
valor se aproxima la función f x cuando
x tiende a menos infinito es decir
cuando x se hace cada vez más y más y
más negativo verdad entonces como
siempre te invito a que hagas una pausa
y trates de resolver este problema por
tu propia cuenta
bueno tratemos de hacerlo todos juntos a
mí sobre todo lo que lo que me gusta
mucho cuando trabajo este tipo de
problemas es reescribir la función vamos
a reescribir la función f x que es 7 x
cuadrada menos 2 x todo esto dividido
entre 15 x más 5 muy bien esta es
nuestra función original verdad y
digamos una técnica interesante para
resolver este tipo de problemas es
dividir el numerador y el denominador
entre la potencia de x con el exponente
más grande que podamos encontrar en el
denominador entonces en este caso por
supuesto estaríamos hablando de este
verdad aquí tenemos la potencia digamos
con el exponente más grande en x que
podemos hallar en el denominador
entonces lo que vamos a hacer es dividir
o si quieres puedes pensarlo como
multiplicar por 1 entre x el numerador y
también multiplicar por 1 entre
x el denominador verdad y en realidad
cuando multiplicamos por digamos el
mismo factor tanto en el numerador como
en el denominador en realidad estamos
multiplicando por 1 verdad aquí tenemos
uno entre x dividido entre 1 entre x que
es 1 así que en realidad no estamos
cambiando ningún valor de esta expresión
verdad entonces lo que nos permite hacer
esto es que ahora vamos a poder
reescribir esta función de una forma que
sea más fácil de analizar el
comportamiento cuando x se aproxime a
menos infinito así que vamos a
reescribir esto verdad esto simplemente
será igual a 7x cuadrada que multiplica
x 1 entre x tendremos simplemente 7x
verdad y menos 2x x 1 entre x
simplemente es menos dos luego dividimos
entre el 15 x x 1 entre x que es
simplemente
+ 5 que multiplica a 1 entre x eso
simplemente será 5 entre x muy bien
entonces esta expresión que hemos
encontrado aquí esta expresión que hemos
encontrado aquí es equivalente a la que
teníamos anteriormente
lo único digamos que hemos ganado y
expresando lo de esta forma es que será
más fácil analizar el comportamiento de
esta función cuando x se aproxime a
menos infinito muy bien entonces lo que
podemos observar es qué pasa con los
términos en donde aparece x por ejemplo
aquí en el numerador tenemos este
término 7x entonces en realidad este
término se hace muy grande y negativo
cuando x se digamos tiende a menos
infinito verdad este término se hace muy
muy grande pero con valores negativos y
si esto es muy muy grande con valores
negativos al restarle 2 pues en realidad
sigue siendo un número muy muy grande
con valores negativos verdad
cuando dividimos aquí tenemos 15 + 5
entre x así que perdón si tenemos 15 + 5
entre x este término de aquí este
término de aquí es 5 dividido entre un
número muy muy grande aunque sea
negativo verdad el punto es que cuando
dividimos un número entre un número muy
grande esto se va a aproximar cada vez
más a 0 aunque se va a aproximar con
valores negativos verdad porque el
denominador sería negativo entonces aquí
tenemos que todo el denominador va a
parecerse simplemente a 15 verdad
entonces como como podríamos concluir
tenemos un número que es muy muy grande
con valores negativos luego le restamos
2 que pues prácticamente no le hace nada
verdad y luego dividimos entre 15 más un
número que prácticamente 0 verdad pero
si ya teníamos aquí arriba un número que
era muy muy grande con valores negativos
y dividimos entre 15 pues en realidad
seguimos teniendo un número
muy grande con valores negativos así que
toda esta función va a atender a menos
infinito verdad entonces ahora una forma
en la que también podríamos abordar este
problema es pensar en los términos que
van a dominar tanto en el numerador como
en el denominador de hecho de hecho a mí
me gusta más esta técnica entonces vamos
a ver cómo sería esto nosotros tenemos
quiénes fx aquí tenemos f x es 7 bueno
de una vez lo voy a hacer si pensamos en
los términos dominantes de esta función
verdad si pensamos en los términos
dominantes pues tenemos que pensar en
aquellas potencias de x que tengan el
exponente más grande verdad porque así
cuando x sea muy muy grande o digamos
que tenga una magnitud grande entonces
vamos a ponerlo así para x grande y
cuando nos referimos a que x sea grande
estamos pensando en que su valor
absoluto o también
que le llamamos magnitud verdad su valor
absoluto o su magnitud es muy grande en
eso estamos pensando cuando esto ocurre
pues justamente el término dominante en
el numerador es 7x cuadrada y el término
dominante en el denominador es 15 x así
que esta función fx se va a parecer a 7x
cuadrada en el numerador y 15 x en el
denominador verdad entonces si nosotros
vemos a quienes esto realmente
simplemente tendremos 7x dividido entre
15 y esto es muy fácil de ver verdad que
es lo que va a ocurrir cuando x tiende a
menos infinito porque aquí tenemos 715
abós de un número que es cada vez más y
más negativo entonces esto realmente se
ve que se hará menos infinito cuando x
tiende a menos infinito
entonces hagamos otro ejercicio más
vamos a hacer otro ejercicio
aquí tenemos aquí tenemos esta función q
de x que es 6x quinta menos 2 dividido
entre 3x a la 2 más x a la 9 nos dice
encuentra la a sin tota horizontal de q
y como siempre trata de resolverlo
primero por tu propia cuenta aunque de
todos modos lo vamos a hacer todos
juntos muy bien entonces cuando cuando
se refiere encontrar la acin tota
horizontal de una función en realidad
estamos pensando digamos en el valor al
que se aproxima nuestra función q de x
cuando x tiende a infinito o cuando x
tiende a menos infinito verdad es decir
vamos vamos a ver digamos un ejemplo
gráfico digamos que nosotros tenemos
aquí nuestros ejes de coordenadas
ahí está el eje horizontal el eje
vertical y digamos que tenemos una
función que en igualados e igualados
tiene una cinta horizontal entonces
quizás la función de la que estemos
hablando no sé cómo podría verse a lo
mejor se ve algo así pero el punto es
que cuando x se hace cada vez más más
grande este esta función se va a
aparecer cada vez más al valor de
igualados verdad la función tiende a 2
cuando x tiende a infinito y alomejor
ocurre también que por el lado izquierdo
quién sabe cómo se vea pero cuando x
tiende a menos infinito esa función se
va a aparecer a 2 sin llegar a hacer dos
verdades es la idea importante de lajas
into estás nunca alcanzan ese valor muy
bien quizás también podríamos verlo de
esta otra forma a lo mejor tenemos una
función que por ejemplo aquí tenga una a
sin tota vertical verdad es decir que
cuando se aproxime a este valor de x
tiende pues no sé digamos a menos
infinito entonces
podría verse algo así verdad aquí
tenemos un asiento está horizontal pero
también tenemos una cinta vertical en
este valor verdad y quizás del lado
derecho viene desde acá arriba y se va
aproximando a este valor de igual a 2
cuando x se hace muy muy grande verdad
entonces podemos tener varias varios
tipos de comportamientos veamos qué es
lo que ocurre con nuestra función q de x
para eso vamos a reescribir la aquí
vamos a poner q de x q de x pues como
como lo vimos en el ejemplo anterior lo
que tenemos que hacer es dividir el
numerador y el denominador entre la
potencia de x con el exponente más
grande en este caso sería x a la 9
verdad entonces si dividimos esto entre
x a la 9 tendríamos 6 x a la 5 entre
quizá la 9 eso es 6
6 dividido entre x a la 4
no se ve muy bien a la 4 - 2 / / x a la
9 y luego el denominador también vamos a
dividirlo entre quizá la 9 así que
tendremos 3x cuadrada entre x a la 9
esto es 3 entre x a la 7 más x a la 9
entre x a la 9 que es 1
entonces pensemos qué es lo que ocurre
con cada uno de estos términos cuando x
se hace muy muy grande ya sea digamos
que tiende a infinito oa menos infinito
bueno pues aquí estaríamos dividiendo 6
entre un número muy muy grande ya sea
positivo o negativo así que esto se va a
aparecer a 0 lo mismo va a ocurrir con
este término verdad 2 dividido entre un
número muy grande positivo o negativo no
importa se verá digamos de tenderá a
cero verdad lo mismo ocurre con este
término en el denominador esto tenderá a
0 porque 3 dividido entre un número muy
grande se parece a 0 verdad y aquí
finalmente simplemente nos queda este
este número esta constante que es 1
entonces lo que podemos observar es que
en el numerador se aproxima 0 y en el
denominador se aproxima a 1 entonces
esta función se parece a 0 entre 1 que
es 0 verdad es decir q de x tiende a
cero cuando x tiende a infinito oa menos
infinito es decir la cinta horizontal
la recta de igual a cero veamos un
último ejercicio
aquí tenemos otra función f x aquí nos
dan esta función y nos preguntan a qué
valor se aproxima la función f x cuando
x tiende a menos infinito muy bien
entonces hagamos el digamos la misma
técnica que hemos estado utilizando
tomamos fx y dividimos tanto en el
numerador como en el denominador entre
la potencia con el exponente más grande
que tenemos en x en el denominador que
en este caso es x a la cuarta verdad
entonces dividimos tanto arriba como
abajo entre x a la cuarta y obtenemos lo
siguiente de hecho lo voy a poner quizás
acá
del lado derecho
para ponerlo del lado derecho vamos a
dividir entre este término verdad
entonces tendremos 3x cuarta entre x
cuarta simplemente será 3 menos 7 x
cuadrado entre x cuarta es 7 sobre x
cuadrada y menos uno dividido entre x
cuarta es uno menos 1 entre x cuarta
todo esto va dividido entre x cuarta
entre x cuarta es 1 luego tenemos menos
2x cúbico me perdón menos 2 x cúbica
entre x a la cuarta es menos 2 sobre x
verdad
y luego tenemos más 3 dividido entre x a
la cuarta entonces nuevamente podemos
ver que este término de aquí se va a
aproximar a 0 verdad este término de
aquí se va aproximando a 0 este también
se aproxima a 0 y finalmente este
también todo esto porque son constantes
divididas entre números cada vez más y
más grandes entonces concluimos que esta
función tiende a 3 entre 1 que podemos
decir que es 3 verdad entonces esta es
digamos este es el valor que toma f x
cuando x tiende a menos infinito otra
forma de pensar este problema es digamos
considerando los términos dominantes
verdad este sería el término dominante
en el numerador este sería el término
dominante en el denominador y para
cuando x es muy muy grande es decir
cuando existir lea menos infinito estos
términos van a ser digamos despreciables
porque estos son los términos que crecen
más
más rápido entonces podemos escribir que
fx se parece a 3x a la cuarta que es el
término dominante en el numerador
dividido entre x a la cuarta que es el
término dominante en el denominador
verdad y esto es para valores de x con
digamos de magnitud grande verdad es
decir de valor absoluto grande magnitud
grande grande muy bien entonces aquí
simplemente podemos ver que las equis
cuartas se cancelan y concluimos que fx
se parece a tres cuando x tiene una
magnitud grande así que esa es otra
forma en la que podrías digamos abordar
este problema